our top story this hour much of the
nation remains in the grip of an intense
heat wave excessive heat warnings and
advisories are in effect for millions of
americans and at least 28 states across
the country hot dry weather has sparked
wildfires in many places including
mariposa county in central california in
phoenix the temperature is expected to
reach 109 degrees today but as one of
the hottest cities in the u.s phoenix is
on the road to do something about it ben
tracy has more
phoenix is trying to beat the heat by
turning its black asphalt streets gray
this special sealant reflects rather
than absorbs all that hot desert sun 73
miles of the city is now covered with
this yes kate gallego is the city's
mayor she says this so-called cool
pavement is 10 to 12 degrees cooler to
the touch than traditional asphalt
we saw a version of it being made inside
this phoenix warehouse where it goes by
the name solar gray and 10 to 12 degrees
cooler that makes a big difference when
you're talking about what that's doing
citywide our residents say they can feel
the difference climate change is
cranking up the heat in the nation's
hottest large city 2020 was phoenix's
hottest summer ever with 50 days at or
above 110 degrees and a record 28 nights
when the temperature never dropped below
90.
we are seeing every summer higher
temperatures both during the day and
less cooling overnight
cities are warming at twice the global
average because buildings in pavement
absorb and trap so much heat phoenix los
angeles and miami have named chief heat
officers to find ways to prevent the
often deadly impacts of extreme heat
here in phoenix the number of people who
die from homicides every year is about
on par with the number of people who die
from heat david hondula heads the heat
response office in the phoenix area heat
is now killing about 300 people a year
this is a problem that's only going to
get worse so we need to do better we
need to do more we need to be doing it
faster the city is creating 100 cool
corridors planting hundreds of trees
whose shade can drop the ambient air
temperature by about 30 to 40 degrees
compared to full sun phoenix is also
experimenting with reflective roofs and
cooling sidewalks we could wind up with
a phoenix of the future that's cooler
than the one we have today even as
global warming continues
and in a warming world gray could be the
new black for cbs saturday morning i'm
ben tracy in phoenix
[Music]
you know that gray asphalt the first
thing i thought of my dog hurt his paw
his pad because of the heat because of
the feet on the pavement
what an amazing thing that would be even
for pets as well
helps everybody yeah but don't we know
that black attracts and
white reflects it takes us a while to
learn things sometimes sometimes i think